هذا هو الخط الأمامي في البحث عن
omicron في الولايات المتحدة
بعد الانتهاء من هذا
الاختبار الطمع غير المريح في كثير من الأحيان ، فأنت تقوم بعمل
رائع لفتاة الفأرة التالية
، وعادة ما يتم شحنها إلى مكان مثل
مختبرات ماكو الطبية
خارج رالي شمال كارولينا على بعد عشرة آلاف
قدم مربع  مجرد الرغبة في معالجة
عينات تسلسل ماكو المأخوذة في أكثر من
أربعين ولاية ، وثلاثين ألفًا في اليوم هو
العدد الذي نعالجه الآن ، لذا
فإن حوالي مائة ألف أو نحو ذلك
أسبوعيًا من
المعامل مثل هذه هي المفتاح في اكتشاف
متغير omicron في الولايات المتحدة
لأن  لما فعلوه بعد
تحديد اختبار إيجابي حتى
الآن ، نحن في النقطة التي نرتب فيها
تسلسلًا لكل إيجابية نحصل عليها من اختبار
تسلسل الجينوم المعقد
والمكلف الذي يكشف عن
النسب الجينية الدقيقة للفيروس هو
الطريقة الوحيدة لتحديد جديد
متغيرات
clovid 19 كان ماكو واحدًا من أكثر من 60 معملًا
تقوم بالتسلسل لشبكة مراقبة الإجهاد الوطنية التابعة لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض.
يستغرق ما بين يومين إلى ثلاثة أيام
للحصول فعليًا
على التسلسل بشكل كامل من تأكيد
العينة على أنها إيجابية لتجهيز
المكتبة للحمض النووي ، ثم إلى التسلسل الفعلي
لتلك المكتبة
، حيث أعلنت منظمة الصحة العالمية ومركز
السيطرة على الأمراض أن أوميكرون متغير
مثير للقلق بعد أن تم وضع علامة عليه من قبل
العلماء في  جنوب إفريقيا ، تؤدي طفرة في
متغير omicron إلى
نتيجة اختبار غريبة تسمى تسرب الجين s
والجين هو المنحنى الأزرق ومن ثم يكون
المنحنى الأخضر هو الجين s
الذي يكون عادةً موجودًا معهم ،
نعم عادةً ما يتم تجميعهم جميعًا
بشكل وثيق جدًا  معًا مما يجعل من
السهل اكتشاف حالة مشبوهة من أجل
التسلسل المعجل ، لدينا حوالي ست
عينات في الوقت الحالي
بها ترك جين التوقيع هذا
ولكن التسلسل مطلوب لتأكيد
omicron لأنه ليس البديل الوحيد
مع هذا النوع من العلامات
يقول العلماء في mako  لقد رأوا العديد من
المتغيرات المختلفة طوال
الوباء ، بعضها مثل دلتا أصبحت
السلالة المهيمنة بينما يتلاشى البعض الآخر
بسرعة أو لا يأخذها أبدًا  في الوقت الحالي
، لا توجد طريقة لمعرفة نوع
التأثير الذي يمكن أن يحدثه omicron علينا ،
لكنهم يتفقون على أنه عندما يتعلق الأمر
بتكسير معرفة kovid ، فإن القوة في كل
مرة ينتقل فيها من شخص إلى
شخص آخر ، فهذه فرصة
أخرى للفيروس للتحور و  التغيير إلى
شيء مختلف حتى تعرف أن
القدرة على مراقبته يسلط الضوء حقًا
على أهمية الاختبار بشكل صحيح لأنه
بدون الاختبار ليس لديك حقًا
خط أساس لفهم ما يجري